herzlich willkommen wie die antiken
philosophen war klar wer keine freunde
hat der hat auch kein gutes leben
und ganz ähnlich sieht das mein heutiger
gast
ina schmidt ist philosophin hat sich
intensiv mit dem thema freundschaft
auseinander gesetzt und meint gute
freunde würden uns letztlich zu besseren
menschen machen
und bevor wir gründlich über die
freundschaft nachdenken hören wir uns
eine legendäre hymne an die freundschaft
an interpretiert von joe cocker
und auch die antiken
ich das gesagt habe haben ein loblied
auf die freundschaft gesungen und gesagt
sei die grundlage für ein gutes und
glückliches leben sehen sie das auch so
ja auf jeden fall also es ist natürlich
dann eine schwierige frage weil man dann
natürlich direkt zur nächsten frage
kommt uns nicht überlegt was bedeutet
denn das eigentlich als was bedeutet
diese form von freundschaft die einem
die grundlage für ein gutes und
gelingendes und glücks weniges jahres
das ja gesagt hat leben sein kann aber
erst mal würde ich das auf jeden fall
genauso unterstreichen
und warum ist freundschaft denn so
wichtig was macht freundschaft so
zentral für das glück naja ich glaube
wir sind uns alle darüber einig dass ein
leben das wir in einsamkeit verbringen
also ohne soziale beziehungen ein leben
ist dass wir einfach auch aus einem ganz
persönlichen gefühle heraus nicht als
glücklich beschreiben würden und
aristoteles war ja der festen
überzeugung dass wir als soziale und
gesellige wesen und auf den weg in unser
leben machen gewerben in eine familie in
eine gemeinschaft in einen kontext
geboren und das was die freundschaft
eben anderen sozialen beziehungen voraus
hat ist dass wir sie als eine
wohlwollende und ebenfalls eine
bereichernde beziehung zwischen menschen
die wir auf eine besondere weise
anziehend finden oder den wir zugeneigt
sind ohne dass wir das immer erkennen
oder erklären können auswählen und eben
auch darin einen blick begleiter oder
menschen erkennen die uns helfen können
dieses leben eben zu einem glücklichen
zu machen
und genau diese besondere form der
beziehung die die freundschaft ist
werden wir werden ja heute sprechen sie
haben dieses buch hier geschrieben auf
die freundschaft und
ich habe mich gefragt habt einen eigenen
haus lösung persönliches erlebnis das
sie auf das thema geschubst hat es war
eher ein prozess würde ich sagen also
eine lebensphase in der freundschaft ein
großes thema in verschiedenen stellen
gewesen ist also sich wandelnde
freundschaften auch in meinem leben ich
habe drei kinder viel zeit und ging
einfach dann in familiäre zusammenhänge
die frage die pflege ich freunde welche
freunde pflege ich warum gehen
freundschaften
an manchen stellen auch zu ende
gekoppelt dann an die themen wie meine
kinder mit dem thema freundschaft
verbunden haben also wo dann das thema
im kindergarten plötzlich eine große
rolle gespielt hat und dann kam mediale
erlebnisse dazu also ich wurde dann in
irgendwelchen werbe-mails als liebe
freundin angesprochen und so kam sie aus
verschiedenen zusammenhängen immer
wieder begrifflichkeiten die im kontext
mit freundschaften rolle gespielt haben
die dann irgendwann dafür gesorgt habe
ich nicht gedacht ich möchte das
eigentlich gerne mal rausfinden vor dem
philosophischen hintergrund wenig zum
teil zumindest zu der zeit schon hatte
was dieser begriff eigentlich bedeutet
wie viele frauen geworben sie das ist
eine schwere frage also ich glaube ich
würde drei menschen ganz spontan und als
wirklich freunde im waren also im sinne
dieser aristotelischen freundschaft
einer einer trefflichen freundschaft
beschreiben und darüber hinaus gibt es
menschen von denen ich glaube dass sie
freunde sind aber eben daneben auf
verschiedene kontexte bezogen also wo es
noch eine differenzierung vielleicht
geben und haben sie so etwas wie eine
beste freundin oder einen besten freund
ich habe meine schwester was natürlich
eine problematik ist auf die wir
vielleicht auch sogar noch kommen werden
als eine freundin von der ich sagen
würde dass sie sehr viele aspekte
erfüllt aber sie ist nun mal meine
schwester und insofern ist da eine eine
überlegung was diese freundschaft
ausmacht schon sozusagen innewohnt in
dieser beziehung aber so was wie eine
busenfreundin oder einer young
langjährige beste freundin habe ich
nicht und einen männlichen
freund haben wir das ich habe
verschiedene männliche freunde aber ich
würde sagen dass eben auch die der
kontext freundschaft in meiner beziehung
zu meinem mann eine ganz große rolle
spielt also wenn man zum beispiel
freunde als jemandem bezeichnet oder
dein freund als jemanden bezeichnen
würde
mit dem man dinge teilen sie einem durch
den kopf gehen oder wo es darum geht
sofort in einen austausch gehen zu
wollen weil man weiß der andere hat ein
verständnis für das was einen vielleicht
als frage wichtig ist dann wäre mein
mann der erste die nicht fragen würde
und da würde ich sagen dass es eben eine
freundschaftliche ebene also würden sie
sagen liebe und freundschaft das
schließlich nicht er sondern ihr mann
ist so etwas wie ihr bester freund oder
ein beste genannt ist das typisch ist
haben sie so ein bisschen geschildert
sie haben drei sehr enge freundinnen
dann so etwas weiteren kreis - menschen
die neu stehen aber was sie bestimmte
aspekte ausleben von sich sie als ganzes
weiß man da empirisch und wissen wie die
menschen ticken wie viele freunde die
meisten haben und ob sie meine besten
freunde haben oder anders
geschlechtliche also es ist so dass in
untersuchungen auch in den
veranstaltungen oder gesprächen die ich
zu diesem thema jetzt schon ende zehn
jahren viel geführt haben kann man sich
fast immer auf diese handvoll einigen
also viele sagen so mehr als eine
handvoll freunde habe ich eigentlich
nicht wenn ich genau darüber nachdenke
und das ist etwas was ich auch
widerspiegelt in untersuchen dass es
dann zu etwas anderem wird dass man
häufig über diese handvoll hinaus dann
eher von bekanntschaften spricht dann
sind das vielleicht gute nachbarn oder
sind sport bekanntschaften wo man sagen
wir das ist ein guter kumpel mit dem
gegner im tennis nochmal wir trinken
also es sind andere qualitäten die da
eine rolle spielen als bei diesen drei
vier oder fünf manche menschen sagen
auch der nur einen besten freund und wir
brauchen sie auch nicht
jetzt schauen wir uns genau an was diese
drei denn ausmacht also die zu guten
freunden macht muss was ist da ihre
antwort was macht einen freund zu einem
freund also erstmal würde ich versuchen
das jetzt mal losgelöst von meinen
persönlichen erfahrungen ist
freundschaft etwas was immer mit einem
bestimmten vertraut sein mit einer
erkenntnis des anderen um dieser person
selbst
willen zu tun hat wo also in dem
vertraut seien schon mal das vertrauen
steckt aber eben auch gleichzeitig eine
gewisse zeit die notwendig ist damit wir
zum vertrauten werden können und was
freundschaft immer auch auszeichnet ist
eine freiwilligkeit also wir haben uns
diesen menschen als jemanden ausgesucht
auch wenn wir manchmal das gefühl haben
es war so etwas zwingen ist wir sind
jemandem begegnet es gab so eine art
seelenverwandtschaft das sagt
aristoteles ja auch dass wir eine
seelische ähnlichkeit in dem anderen
wiederfinden bis hin zu der vorstellung
dass es eine seele in zwei körpern ist
sie da eine rolle spielt aber diese
verwandtschaft auf freiwilliger basis
die uns dann zu einem vertrauten paar
also wenn es eine zweier freundschaft
ist werden lässt ist das was glaube ich
in jeder ernst zu nehmen oder wahren
freundschaft eine rolle spielen muss
sie haben jetzt schon mehrmals
aristoteles erwähnt wie vermieter noch
genauer über seine position sprechen
diese idee der seelenverwandtschaft oder
der nähe die man empfindet das vertrauen
das man hat das verständnis man kennt
sich man hat den eindruck man kennt sich
sehr gut da hin steckt doch auch eine
gefahr nämlich die gefahr der
verletzlichkeit wenn man was nicht
verraten wird verletzt wird durch auch
in treviso viel von einem wissen das ist
ein risiko auch immer nicht mit
freundschaft einzurücken
ja wobei natürlich die frage ist ob das
wirklich ein risiko sein muss wenn wir
jemandem diesen blick auf uns selbst
eröffnen oder ob nicht eigentlich das
was wir an gewinn am chance an potenzial
darin auch schaffen oder ermöglichen ob
das liegt das eigentlich schon
interessante daran ist also natürlich
wird jeder offenheit auch die gefahr
dass es da eine verletzung oder eine
verletzung entstehen kann aber es hängt
ja sehr damit zusammen welches
menschenbild oder welches weltbild wir
haben was geschieht wenn wir uns öffnen
wenn wir sichtbar werden wenn wir auch
uns sozusagen hingeben und uns in dem
vertrauen darauf dass der andere kein
missbrauch
damit übt eigentlich eine chance darin
sehen uns jemandem so zu offenbaren dass
wir eben auch ein
einen austausch ermöglichen denn nur
dann wirklich funktionieren kann wenn
wir uns öffnen
wie ist der freund oder die freundin
immer auch so etwas wie ein spiegel
hast du nicht lernen und können wäre ich
wirklich bin im besten sinne ja also die
möglichkeit sich zu spiegeln wenn wir
uns dann geöffnet haben ist natürlich
etwas wo drin auch diese vorstellung
lebt dass wir uns durch freundschaft
weiter entwickeln also dass etwas in der
freundschaft nicht nur eine bereicherung
in dem moment in dem wir mit dem anderen
gerade einen schönen moment erleben oder
angewiesen
gute zeit haben seinen urlaub verbringen
oder was auch immer sondern dass es
etwas gibt was uns in diesem spiegel
auch etwas über uns selbst eröffnet was
wir vielleicht vorher nicht kannten was
nur durch den anderen und in der in
dieser letzten absolutheit des
andersseins auch möglich wird aber dass
diese dieser spielt ostberg das kann ja
doch auch zu einem korsett werden oder
kann mich einengen kann ich mir
vorstellen weil man lange in einer
langen freundschaft denkt man man kennt
den anderen und andere und die ist
einfach so und man lässt sie dann
überhaupt ich den freiraum sich zur
entwicklung und sich neu zu erfinden
ja auch da ist natürlich die frage
welche bedingungen also auch welche
offenheit in der kommunikation also in
der in dem austausch selig mit dem oder
der freundin führe ist sozusagen das
konstitutive für das was er da
freundschaft nennen
also geht es darum den anderen in dem
erkennen zu wollen wie ich glaube dass
er zu sein hat oder dass ich ihn
vielleicht sogar gerne hätte also steckt
eine bestimmte erwartungshaltung auch
von meiner seite drin wie ein freund zu
sein hat oder ist das konstitutive
gerade diese offenheit in der ich sogar
von dem anderen erwarte dass er sich
öffnet verändert entwickelt in den
einzelnen lebensphasen nicht derselbe
bleibt sondern sozusagen in einer
kontingenten veränderung auch mit mir
selber ein weg geht
jetzt gibt es dieses sprichwort der
freund ist da wenn man not hat also ist
derjenige der not hilft wenn ich im
spital liege im krankenbett
dann kann ich sagen wer wirklich ein
freund ist nämlich der der nicht
besuchen konnte stimmt das
ja und nein also ich finde da steckt ja
dieser gedanke der freundschaft pflicht
sozusagen auch drin der auch in der
philosophie mehr oder weniger stark
betont worden ist also es gibt phasen in
denen eben diese diese verpflichtung in
der freundschaft viel größer oder eine
viel größere rolle gespielt hat als in
anderen
ich glaube dass wir heute darin manchmal
eben dann doch so was wie ein korsett
stören weil wir glauben dass wir in
diesen situationen eben eine bestimmte
erwartung haben dürfen
vielleicht wird andersrum er eine eine
möglichkeit freundschaft zu erkennen
indem wir eben nicht erwarten was zu
geschehen hat und uns dann aber trotzdem
darüber freuen wenn sich sozusagen
freundschaft bestätigt in diesen krisen
momenten oder in dem moment in dem ich
im spital liegen ohne dass ich sage du
bist nicht mehr mein freund wenn ich
mich im krankenhaus besucht aber
freundschaft ist schon mit bestimmten
verpflichtungen auch verbunden mit
bestimmten erwartungen die ich
berechtigterweise haben darf ich würde
sagen es sind verbindlichkeiten die eine
rolle in der freundschaft spielen also
was sie einen ein versprechen das ich
dem anderen gäbe was aber nicht zwingend
auf die erwartung des anderen eingehen
muss also es gibt freundschaften die
leben durch andere verbindlichkeiten als
andere und das herauszufinden und zu
sagen was ist es eigentlich was in
unserer freundschaft eine besondere
rolle spielt vielleicht gibt es einen
freund der keine fuß und krankenhäuser
setzen kann weil es ihm mit irgendeiner
angst die er selber hat konfrontiert und
ich weiß er werde nie im leben an meinen
krankenbett kommen und trotzdem bleibt
ein wichtiger und guter freund in meinem
leben aber darum zu wissen ist eben auch
ein teil dieser vertrautheit die den
anderen als jemanden annimmt der bleiben
kann wie er ist und der mir immer auch
ein bisschen ähnlich ist das sagen sie
ja auch freunde sind immer ein
bestimmter weise gleich gesehen die sie
teilen etwas bestimmte interessen oder
bestimmte werte sogar eine grundlegende
ansichten einen bestimmten blick auf die
welt ja weil diese ähnlichkeit eben
glaube ich auch manchmal etwas
missverständlich es hat war ich glaube
es geht eher um eine gleichwertigkeit in
freundschaften also
um eine augenhöhe zu sagen die nicht
unbedingt was damit zu tun hat dass man
ähnliche interessen oder ähnliche werte
haben muss es hilft natürlich um ein
gemeinsames verständnis zu haben es gibt
aber auch freundschaften die leben durch
ein hohes maß an kontroverse eben genau
in diesen konflikten vielleicht oder in
einer besonderen streitkultur oder in
einer komplementarität von interessen zu
etwas drittel zu kommen was ohne den
freund nicht möglich wäre
es gibt ja immer wieder diese beispiele
von freundschaften zwischen sehr
verschiedenen menschen etwa die wahre
geschichte einer freundschaft zwischen
dem reichen adligen tetraplegiker
philipp und den kleinkriminellen
geriatrie es aus den ball ließ die
geschichte wurde 2011 verfilmt unter dem
titel ziemlich beste freunde
ich bin bereit sich für einen monat
oktober einzustellen ich würde sie
halten keine zwei wochen gerechnet
[Musik]
da machen sich sorgen um dich gerade du
müsstest vorsichtig sein
die jungs aus der vorstadt kennen kein
mittel das ist genau das was ich will
kein mitleid
[Musik]
das lehne ich ab
hat sie doch was haben wir denn so leid
es mir tut wir müssen pragmatisch denken
[Musik]
ein großartiger film
ich war wirklich hin und weg was lehrt
uns dieser film über über freundschaft
ja eine ganze menge würde ich sagen also
ich genau weil wir über dieses thema der
ähnlichkeit gesprochen haben macht der
film natürlich genau diese frage war
offensichtlich er sich zu fragen wie
können sich eigentlich diese beiden
männer auf so eine intensive weise
befreunden obwohl man den eindruck hat
im ersten moment zumindest dass sie
eigentlich gar nichts mehr bewirken so
und trotzdem ist es ja so und das finde
ich eben auch ganz interessant weil ich
denn nun auch eine wahre geschichte ist
die zumindest der anlass für diesen film
war dass es da eine ähnlichkeit gibt die
sozusagen unter den unter der oberfläche
deutlichen also dass sich auch der diese
rand dieses rand leben oder dieses diese
existenz am rande der gesellschaft durch
eine wirkliche form der behinderung auf
beiden seiten zu so einem elementaren
zentrum in den beiden lebensgeschichten
verwirklicht hat und das in diesen mut
und diese absolute offenheit die ja
wirklich in dem film immer und immer
wieder deutlich wird diese ähnlichkeit
zu so einer einer starken bande
entwickelt ist glaube ich etwas was wir
manchmal in vielen freundschaften die
uns vielleicht so vor augen sind wenn
wir an unsere eigenen freundschaften
denken so ein bisschen fehlt also eine
unglaublich existenzielle lebendigkeit
die eigentlich aus einer eine krise oder
auch einer einer not heraus entsteht und
die beiden protagonisten nähern sich
dann ja auch nicht den eindruck dass sie
lernen voneinander die lernen sozusagen
die welt auf neue weise zu sehen
plötzlich zu lachen in dieser europa wo
der anbau nicht eher sinkt
das zeigt man man wird ein anderer
endlich in freundschaften
ja also schön finde ich eben auch diesen
punkt des humors also es gibt von von
max frisch ja auch diesen sehr schönen
fragebogen zur freundschaft wo eine der
fragen lautet gibt es freundschaft ohne
cetin humor was ich eine unglaublich
schöne frage übrigens finde wenn man
auch da mal so ein bisschen in seiner
eigenen freundschaftsgeschichte schaut
ja und man wird sich möglicherweise
ähnlicher in dem man sich aber eben auch
in dieser offenheit zumutet das ist ja
das was eben diese frage ist welche
distanz sie hinterlasse ich zu wie viel
bereitschaft bringe ich mit mit
demjenigen auszuliefern als jemand der
mich spiegeln darf und wie viel
sicherheit habe ich trotzdem dass
derjenige eben das was er da sieht mich
missbräuchlich vielleicht als als
bewertung oder so für meinen für meine
eigene person ausnutzten
jetzt würde ich sagen diese diese
verschiedenheit oder diese freundschaft
zwischen sehr verschiedenen ist fast
schon ein topos als wenn man sieht
irgendwie zum beispiel asterix und
obelix laurel und hardy und so weiter
verkörpern genau diese gegensätze was
will man damit uns zeigen ist das eine
super sich werbebotschaft zu sagen
freundschaft sprengt soziale beamten war
was steckt dahinter
ich glaube dass es einen ein ausdruck
auch von polarität ist die werden ganz
vielen verschiedenen stellen des lebens
erleben vor der wir aber häufig eher
angst haben oder von der wir das gefühl
haben da entsteht eine spannung oder
eine eine problematik deswegen suchen
wir vielleicht gleichartigkeit oder
ähnlichkeit im sinne von gleichheit
stärker stellen dann aber auch fest dass
da natürlich noch andere dynamik dann
manchmal nicht möglich ist also die
dieses konfliktpotenzial oder diese
kraft die auch aus polaren
freundschaftsbeziehungen entsteht ist
natürlich nicht möglich wenn wir uns so
ähnlich werden aber ich glaube es
interessante haben am anfang gesagt man
muss nicht bestimmte werte teilen nicht
alle aber irgendwas ganz grundlegend
muss man doch bestimmt eine
grundüberzeugung eine grund- haupt- und
ethische ausreicht wer ist man doch
teilen sonst kommt man gerät man die
ganze zeit aneinander
ja auf jeden fall und das glaube ich ist
auch in den beispielen die wir jetzt
gesehen haben oder
die sie genannt haben gegeben das ist
sozusagen ein grundverständnis von dem
was das gute aus macht oder dass das
gute überhaupt eine wichtige komponente
für das ist was wir mit unseren
handlungen anstreben ganz im sinne
vielleicht auch eines platonischen ideal
ist dass das etwas ist was in der
freundschaft nicht unbedingt jeden tag
und ganz bewusst angestrebt werden muss
was aber sozusagen eine art fundament
beschreibt von wo aus wir entscheiden
wie viel unterschiedlichkeit liefe
kontroverse wie viel gleichheit welche
gewohnheit auch an manchen stellen im
sinne von ritualen oder
freundschaftsdiensten freundschafts
pflichten halten wir für wichtig um
diese freundschaft auch als eine praxis
über viele verschiedene jahre und und
entwicklungen und lebensphasen
möglicherweise hinaus lebendig zu
erhalten und dieses gute also diese
dimension diese ethische dimension
spielt dabei aristoteles dem antiken
wieder so eine ganz zentrale rolle
vielleicht können sie kurz erläutern was
seine vorstellungen ist er unterscheidet
ja drei arten von freundschaften
er hat in seiner komischen ethik hat er
ja sozusagen die erste theorie der
freundschaft in der
philosophiegeschichte vorgelegt und hat
eben diese dreiteilung vorgenommen von
der ich glaube dass wir heute immer noch
sehr sehr viel damit anfangen können
also gibt es die nutzen freundschaft die
lust freundschaft und am ende spricht er
von der freundschaft der trefflich in
die eben ganz viel damit zu tun hat dann
herzlich in order to get off genau wer
der tugendhafte wo es eben um die das
gute als anzustrebendes ideal im leben
des einzelnen geht also anders als bei
seinem lehrer plattform als eine hehre
idee sondern wirklich als etwas was die
ethischen ausdrucksweisen unseres
handelns bestimmen soll
und die freundschaft die durch nutzen
oder durch lustgewinn beschrieben ist
kennen wir alle und würden heute
vielleicht sagen das sind dann netzwerke
für geschäftsfreunde unsere stimmen sind
ein halbes heißt man profitiert man von
jemanden deswegen geht man die beziehung
ein mann ist zum beispiel in einer neuen
stadt und leute kennen sich nicht heraus
hat
freunde keine bekannten und das ist dann
nutzen und daraus kann sich so etwas wie
eine wahre freundschaft und kann sich
auch so was wie eine wahre freundschaft
entwickeln aber es gibt sogar
freundschaften von denen man sagen würde
sie sind sogar darauf ausgerichtet es
gibt vielleicht einen kontakt wir
sprechen auch von kontakten die für
einen bestimmten zweck oder eine
bestimmte bereicherung der eigenen
karriere oder des eigenen vorwärtskommen
ist oder vielleicht einfach auch nur zu
einer bestimmten community dazu zu
gehören
einen wert haben und trotzdem geht das
was wir mit dieser person verbinden
darüber hinaus und wir würden es eben
freundschaftlich nennen
aber dieser nutzen ist das was
eigentlich die motivation für diese
beziehung gewesen ist und beide los was
wären dabei spielt die lust freundschaft
beschreibt aristoteles als eine form der
beziehung wo es um die anwesenheit des
anderen geht wo es ist also zu sagen ein
wohlgefühl beschert einfach zeit mit dem
anderen zu verbringen wo wir uns jetzt
nicht auf einen außen nach außen
gerichteten zwecken mit dem anderen
beschäftigen sondern wo wir einfach
einen kleinen genuss ein wohlgefühl
haben wenn wir mit der anderen person
zeit verbringen und dieser sprung in
diese ethische qualität oder die frage
auch die eigene ich mir welt an
wie verstehe ich dinge die für mich von
bedeutung sind wie nutze ich den anderen
eben auch als einem spiegel für meine
ganz persönliche entwicklung ohne dass
es aber dieser diese zweckgerichtet hyde
ist sondern es entsteht einfach eine
bereicherung dadurch dass ich mit dem
anderen in dieser beziehung mein leben
teile der sache zu tun ist sagt auch mit
diesen trefflichen freundin müssen wir
unser leben teilen also ihr schrei
sitzen dann nicht unbedingt alle unter
einem dach
aber wir haben den anderen als eine
wichtige person von bedeutung in unserem
leben und dann können wir durch die
freundschaft zu besseren menschen werden
genau da gibt es dann diese idee eines
moralischen wachstums das klingt dann
ein bisschen pathetisch vielleicht weil
man den friedman hat das als eine ein
ergebnis geschrieben von von dem was
freundschaft möglich machen kann also
dass wir und das haben wir ganz am
anfang auch gesagt dass wir tatsächlich
durch freunde zu besseren menschen
werden können nicht zwingen müssen aber
können
also das heißt danach dass freunde einen
kritisieren sehr ehrlich sind ein fehler
hinweisen oder wie muss ich mir das
vorstellen dass auf jeden fall also ich
glaube das ist auch das was uns in
unserer freundschaft praxis
wahrscheinlich noch einfällt was auch
schwierig ist also woran wir aber
wachsen können indem wir uns auf diese
kritik ein lassen die möglicherweise
durch reflektion oder durch veränderung
des eigenen verhaltens den den eindruck
gewinnen dass wir zu besseren menschen
geworden sind aber es gibt eben auch
diese vorstellung dass man das bessere
in der andersartigkeit des anderen
erkennt also dadurch dass wir bei aller
freundschaft und bei allem verstehen
immer auf einen anderen treffen der der
andere bleibt sehr dass diese zentrale
idee bei emanuel seminars zum beispiel
der dass andere gerade in der
freundschaft als eine art des
geheimnisses des unhintergehbaren sehr
stark hervorhebt und wir durch das
anerkennen dessen eine andere
vorstellung vom guten in dieser
vielfältigkeit und des unlösbaren auch
bekommen und wir damit unsere eigenen
ansprüche an das was wir vielleicht
verstehen erkennen erreichen wollen ein
stück weit zurückstellen
aber jetzt setzt er ist das noch einen
oben drauf er sagt ja die freundschaft
macht uns nicht nur individuell zu
besseren menschen sondern sie ist
wichtig für die gerechtigkeit die
gestaltung einer politischen
gemeinschaft also wenn wir zwischen
freunden etwas platt gesagt braucht es
keine moral keine gerechtigkeit und
insofern kann sie grundlage sein für
eine kleine gemeinschaft für die ethik
einer kleinen gemeint ja das ist
natürlich auch ein hoch interessanter
gedanke also nicht glaube auch
hochaktuell
wenn man sich überlegen würde wie in der
politik wenn wenn in der politischen
landschaft die freundschaft eine andere
rolle spielen würde beziehungsweise wenn
wir uns überlegen was bedeutet denn
eigentlich eine freundschaft über
individuellen hinaus im
gemeinschaftlichen kontexten sei es
jetzt organisationen oder teams oder
familien aber eben auch staaten und wir
uns fragen würde die freundschaft wenn
wir uns dann so wie wir es jetzt
besprochen haben mit
wir beschäftigen würde sie grundlage
politischer entscheidungen werden würden
wir ihnen bestimmte diskussionen so
nicht führen müssen sondern würden
vielleicht tatsächlich in ein anderes
dialogisches verhältnis kommen weil
freundschaft und diese form der
dialogbereitschaft auf kooperation
ausgerichtet ist und es eben auch ein
einverständnis des anderen alb des
anderen geht und was bedeutet das
konkret heißen
können sie ein beispiel geben was das in
politischen zusammenhängen ist dagegen
wird bedeuten könnte na ja es ist
natürlich die also einmal gibt es ja
immer dieses beispiel auch der deutsch
französischen freundschaft und glaube
ich einiges davon tatsächlich im moment
sichtbar würde wo es um einen ein
bemühen geht ein tatsächliches bemühen
in der auseinandersetzung um bestehende
werte wie zwar auch in der diskussion
sind aber die versuchen ein kooperatives
bild von gemeinsamen entscheidungen oder
einer gemeinsamen handlungsgrundlage zu
schaffen sagen was man ganz vorsichtig
und es gibt in anderen politischen
zusammenhängen da braucht man jetzt gar
nicht unbedingt nur nach amerika zu
schauen sondern in verschiedenen ländern
ein sehr viel kontroverses bild was
nicht auf kooperation ausgerichtet ist
sondern auf beschränkung und begrenzung
und betonung des eigenen was ich eben
abgrenzt von dieser vorstellung dass wir
in aller freundschaft eine kooperation
ein kompromiss im besten sinne finden
müssen damit es zu diesem dritten kommen
denn was ich eben nur aus einer
freundschaft speisen kann die eben nicht
auf die gerechtigkeit pochen muss
sondern die sozusagen für sie gegeben
ist also wenn man sich diese
freundschaftliche haltung aneignet in
ganz unterschiedlichen lebens kontexten
sagen sie dann gewinnt man auch so etwas
wie einen freundschaftlichen blick auf
die welt ist man kann sich mit der welt
an freuen uns von pflanzen spannenden
gedanken vielleicht kennen sie den kurz
ausführen was denn das heißt reißen
könnte es ist also ein bisschen ich
finde das ganz schön weil eigentlich
dieser begriff der freundschaft ja auch
in der philosophie schon drin steckt und
eben auch in diesem großen in dieser
sehr groß gedachten vorstellung davon
philosoph als freund beweis
unter weise kennen und diese frage ob
wir eben als freund von etwas über uns
in diesem annähernden denken was die
philosophie auch auszeichnet also einem
nicht besetzenden denken sondern eben
einem forscher in einem fragenden einem
staunenden denken uns etwas an herrn von
dem wir und das ist eben die
grundvoraussetzung von der wir uns
selber natürlich fragen müssen ob wir
sie teilen von dem wir glauben dass sie
einen sozusagen sinnvollen kern hat dem
wir uns wohlwollend nähern wollen
also es hat was mit einer entscheidung
zu tun diese haltung auch einnehmen zu
wollen
die dann natürlich mit erfahrungen und
erlebnissen genähert und gespeist werden
kann um zu wachsen
die aber meines erachtens eben nicht
ohne diese werden das am anfang diese
freiwilligkeit also das nutzen des
freien willens liegt zu dieser haltung
zu bekennen möglich ist ne aber es
bedeute nicht unbedingt dass man es die
welt so nimmt wie sie ist sich an freund
mit der welt die als schreckliche seiten
hat sondern es bedeutet so viel wie
neugier aus der distanz nähe zuzulassen
hinzugehen genau hinzuschauen wir das ja
und ich halte auch natürlich nicht nur
freundschaftlich in einem harmonischen
freundschaft ideal aufzuhalten und zu
sagen wir lassen es so wie es ist damit
es uns allen möglichst gut geht und
werden unsere komfortzone ja nicht zu
nahe an die problematiken irgendeiner
grenz oder irgendeinen anderen geraten
sondern wirklich in der liebe oder
freundschaft zur welt die sich so
engagiert dass sie auch gestalten und
verändern will
ja aber ich meine jetzt noch mal zurück
auf zwischenmenschliche freundschaften
da ist natürlich schon die gefahr dass
man aus loyalität den anderen einfach
immer schützt und bestätigt und so
weiter und irgendwann vor vor vorwissen
abgrenzt und so das ist wieder dieses
einengende und das bringt irgendwie so
eine bestimmte straße hinein
das ist schon die gefahr oder das andere
wird das wäre das ideal was sie zeichnen
aber in der realität wie ich eine ideale
zeichnet sich natürlich eben dadurch aus
dass wir es meistens zumindest nicht
erreichen sonst wäre es kein ideal aber
es ist trotzdem die frage ob wir uns
dieses ideal
sagen jetzt wegweiser suchen also ob es
das ist worauf wir mit unserer
freundschaft praxis hinaus wollen oder
ob wir sagen wir ja meine freunde sind
sozusagen ebenso die die die
stellvertreter für mein wohlgefühl mit
denen habe ich irgendwie nett machen
feierabend da möchte ich keine probleme
haben und dann möchte ich mich einfach
nur ein bisschen zurücklehnen und meinen
spaß haben
er wurde aristoteles sagen das ist
völlig in ordnung und wir können uns
ruhig freundschaft nehmen aber es fällt
eben er in diesem bereich der nutzen
oder der lust freundschaft
wollen wir also diesen schritt weiter
gehen und da sind wir wieder bei der
idee der entscheidung zu einer anderen
form oder vielleicht einer weiteren form
der freundschaft dann geht es eben genau
darum diese schwierigkeiten auch als
schwierigkeiten anzunehmen und in das
eigene handeln zu integrieren und sich
zu fragen lasse ich mich auf dieses
risiko ein
oder eben nicht und diese dimension der
freiheit oder der entscheidung die firma
in bestimmten anderen beziehungen
nämlich in verwandtschaftsbeziehung in
meiner familie
also mein bruder den habe ich mir nicht
ausgesucht
den habe ich einfach keine also ihre
schwester bei ihnen spielt jetzt dass
beides zusammen sie sagen sie haben
nicht freundschaft mit ihrer schwester
ich habe mich gefragt sind wir an einem
zeitpunkt in der geschichte wo es
vielleicht die freundschaft sogar
wichtiger geworden ist aus familie
das kann sein
das liegt aber nicht zwingend daran dass
die freundschaft so zu sagen dass das
die ideale form der menschlichen
beziehung sein muss sondern es liegt
natürlich auch daran dass sich
lebensformen wie wir sie über
jahrhunderte kanten sehr stark verändert
und gewandelt haben gerade in den
letzten jahrzehnten also dass in
großstädten jetzt wie hamburg zum
beispiel sind über die hälfte der
haushalte singlehaushalte wo die rolle
der freundschaft einfach eine ganz
andere geworden ist also auch aus der
notwendigkeit heraus sich eben in einem
beziehungsgeflecht um das glückliche
leben das gute leben zu bemühen und wenn
familie schlicht nicht vorhanden ist
geht es natürlich darum sich in
freundschaften anders einzurichten und
dann sich aber gleichzeitig auch die
frage zu stellen wie tauchen dann da um
die ecke auch wieder verpflichtungen auf
oder notwendigkeiten wie sieht es zum
beispiel solchen freundschaften im
weiter aus wenn man gepflegt werden
müsste also so glaube ich wir können uns
nicht so richtig aus dieser freunde sind
die bessere familie und dann wird alles
gut retten sondern wir müssen uns glaube
ich eher um diese qualitäten dessen ein
bisschen bemühen was macht eigentlich
familiäre beziehung aus was macht
freundschaftliche beziehung aus und wie
mischen sich aber eben auch diese
qualitäten innerhalb der beziehung also
gute freunde wo man sagen wo da ist mir
wie ein bruder oder so dann merkt man ja
es gibt diesen hierarchisierung auch in
der sprache
und was ist das eigentlich was ich dann
meinen ja aber zeugt diese hierarchie
sierung zeigt sich ja dann doch wieder
in der praxis wo man sagt wenn es drauf
ankommt ist für viele dann die familie
doch noch näher als die freunde und dann
ist blut vielleicht doch die chaos war
sein
ja das ist eine eine große eine große
frage weil es natürlich immer die frage
ist warum tue ich das also was ist der
grund dafür dass ich diese blut ist
dicker als wasser these weiterhin glaube
also gibt es da so etwas wie eine
moralische verpflichtung geht daraus
entsteht oder ist es eine erfahrung die
wir gemacht haben es ist sozusagen ein
empirisches erleben oder hat es
tatsächlich das damit zu tun dass ich
mich aus familiären beziehungen einfach
in der form nicht wirklich verabschieden
kann
sie kann man nicht kündigen kann man
nicht gesund und man kann freundschaften
auch wenn es tatsächlich sehr selten der
fall ist also in freundschaften zu einem
schluss zu machen findet auch welten
stadt also die versandten oft eher oder
es wird sich immer weniger gemeldet und
irgendwann hat man das gefühl die
freundschaft hat zu sagen ein
natürliches ende gefunden
aber diese möglichkeit gibt es eben in
der familie nicht und man kann sich dann
anders darauf berufen sie haben gesagt
in bereitet werden gibt es sowas wie
versprechungen die man gegenseitig macht
und bei den freundschaften ist das
sicher so
bei dem wort pflicht sind sie
zurückhaltend aber gibt es nicht so
etwas wie eine selbstverpflichtung wenn
man sich selbst als freund begreift dass
man eben in bestimmten momenten zum
anderen hingeht sich um ihn kümmert
wohlwollend ist und so weiter das ist
doch wie gehört zur definition dessen
was wir freundschaft ja da würde ich
auch sofort also würde ich würde sofort
zustimmen ich glaube nur dass es eben
manchmal die frage ist was es zuerst da
also ist sozusagen diese vorstellung von
verpflichtung etwas was ich bei jeder
freundschaft mit denke als etwas wovon
ich glaube dass ich es erwarten kann
oder ist die freundschaft nicht
sozusagen der grund dafür dass ich ganz
selbstverständlich helfen
das ist also diese vorstellung von
verpflichtung die er immer was auch mit
vertrag oder mit vereinbarung oder etwas
worauf ich mich berufen kann auch wenn
ich gar nicht will
zu tun hat dass wir das eigentlich in
einer freundschaft nicht brauchen
ähnlich wie der gedanke der
gerechtigkeit weil die freundschaft wie
selbstverständlich als grund dafür taugt
das ich helfe da bin mich kümmere pflege
und hege fließt übrigens dieser der
wortstamm der freundschaft eigentlich
bedeutet es gibt in der
philosophiegeschichte ja auch diesen
auszug der herzens freundschaft von
michel de montaigne und der betont ja
auch dieses mal nicht verstand aus
mäßige nicht kognitiv dass es eben keine
pflicht ist sondern dass es dinge sind
die ich als herzensgüte tue oder aus
liebe tun vielleicht gerade erst
freundschaft und da kann man das sagen
auch in der romantik wurde das dann
wieder stärker betont den vergleich zur
aufklärung also bei kant ist dass
freundschaften auch eine sehr sozusagen
verkopfte sache würde ich mal sagen wie
ist ihre haltung dazu sie sind er soll
auf der romantischen nein also ich
glaube es geht wieder ohne das eine noch
das andere und ich glaube wir verdanken
zb dieser romantischen
semantik insbesondere und aber auch
natürlich der der derzeit als solcher
verdanken mir eine eine abgrenzung von
liebe und freundschaft wo genau diese
frage dass des geistes für das dass der
vernunft als teil der freundschaft so
ein bisschen unter die räder gekommen
ist also wo wir uns auch oft schwer tun
wenn wir solche beziehungen eben mit
vernunft in verbindung gebracht sehen
und das gefühl haben wir sollte doch
einfach eine herzens freundschaft sein
es sollte alles aus dem gefühl heraus
gespeist sein und er müsste gar keine
fragen stellen wenn wir dann aber wieder
so ein bisschen zurück kommen zu dieser
überlegung wofür entscheide ich mich in
der freundschaft welche beziehungen sind
es die ich da vielleicht auf
unterschiedliche weise freundschaft
männer dann spielt die bewusste
auseinandersetzung also auch dieses
geistige band und diese ethische
verwirklichung von dem was mir wichtig
ist spielt eine große rolle gerade in
freundschaften weil sie eben nicht
diesen zwingenden charakter hat den wir
häufig der der erotischen oder der
romantischen liebe zu sprechen
jetzt würde ich aber eben nicht als
defizit der freundschaft sondern als
etwas was sie besonders auszeichnet
beschreiben sie würde nicht sagen dass
freundschaft letztlich noch wichtiger
ist als liebe sondern sind zwei
unterschiedlich von der beziehung und
liebe sogar der liebe sogar
freundschaftlich eine form von liebe ja
auf jeden fall
und worin besteht genau die differenz
also in der erotik wahrscheinlich dass
diese dimension zählt ja es ist
körperlich intime ja wobei ich eben auch
da das ist eben eine große frage die man
natürlich jetzt lange könnte mir lange
darüber nachdenken
ich glaube dass durchaus auch erotik
zwischen freunden möglich sein kann
ich glaube nur dass eben in der liebe
und das hat man übrigens in seinem essay
auch sehr schön beschrieben das ist
dieses brennende und dieses auch
gefährliche und zwingende und
leidenschaftliche in der romantischen
oder erotischen liebe sehr viel mehr
gibt und die sozusagen das bestimmende
element ist und dass er das gefühl wir
können uns dem gar nicht erzielen
entziehen also auch die die es hat
gefunkt und es hat geknallt und das sind
einfach so begrifflichkeiten die wir mit
der freundschaft
gewalt ist christina und das ist einfach
es ist wie es ist und ich kann mich
nicht mehr und diese idee einer
freundschaftlichen liebe auf den ersten
blick gibt es durchaus auch
beschreibungen zum beispiel zwischen
hannah arendt und hans jonas gibt es ein
ganz schönes ganz schöne beschreibung
von hans jonas über den moment in dem
man arendt das erste mal gesehen hat und
genau diese dieses verstehen einer
wesens verwandten erkannt haben will
also auch da würde ich von einer liebe
auf den ersten blick sprechen die aber
etwas anderes akzentuiert bewusst um
etwas anderes geht und montania hat das
eben als etwas wärmendes und als etwas
geborgenes etwas halt geben das
beschrieben das klingt alles so schön
aber es gibt auch freundschaften die uns
einfach nicht gut tun wo es konkurrenz
verhältnisse gibt wo es abhängigkeiten
ja natürlich gibt es die uns ist es dann
nur finde ihm das ist ja vielleicht dann
auch die aufgabe des philosophen zu
sagen was ist jetzt in dieser
freundschaft das eigentlich
freundschaftliche und wo kann man dann
wenn man von dieser wenn man diese
beziehung wirklich genau betrachtet und
abhängigkeitsverhältnisse konkurrenz
neid was auch immer feststellt wann kann
man dann eigentlich ernsthaft nicht mehr
von freundschaft sprechen
es ist vielleicht eine wichtige und
unauflösbare soziale beziehung aber es
ist keine freundschaft mehr weil dann
bestimmte kriterien die freiwilligkeit
bereicherung ethisches wachstum und all
diese dinge einfach nicht mehr gegeben
sind
jetzt haben wir noch über das verhältnis
von liebe und freundschaft gesprochen
und das wird der brisant wenn wir an das
geschlechtliche freunde haben wenn man
heterosexuell ist weil dann besteht die
gefahr der erotischen anziehen oder
vielleicht die verführung und bei harry
und sally zum beispiel bei diesem
berühmten film ist es ja genauso dann
klicke sich an einer freundschaft heraus
eine beziehung aber für sie wäre
sozusagen das überhaupt kein problem sie
sagen der begriff freundschaft betont
einfach so ein bisschen dieses
freiheitliche wir können und sie man
auch entscheiden und liebe ist etwas das
uns packt und passiert
ja ich glaube dass sich beide formen von
liebe in einer beziehung nicht
abwechseln aber nebeneinander bestehen
können und ich glaube wir haben häufig
fiel uns uns keinen gefallen in dieser
hierarchisierung davon dass wir sagen es
muss jetzt entweder liebe sein oder
freundschaft und wenn die liebe geht
dann haben wir immerhin noch die
freundschaft also in diesem satz so aber
wir können ja freunde bleiben wird ja
genau das deutlich und sich ganz so
fragen warum haben wir dieses weniger im
kopf wenn wir viel freundschaft ja weil
genau diese verschmelzung für das haben
sie ja gesagt der andere bleibt immer
der andere und bei der liebe hat man
hatten viele heute dieses romantische
ideal dass man schon bei platon findet
der verschmelzung dass man eigentlich
eins ist ich finde meine andere hälfte
und werde so zu einer ganzen person ist
aber ist das so also das ist ja die
große frage ob das in der liebe nicht
mindestens ein genauso großes verheißung
ciné aal ist von dem wir uns fast
permanent durchschreiten und und auch
enttäuscht seien immer wieder abarbeiten
und sich die frage stellt ob nicht
gerade in dieses beziehung auch diese
andersartigkeit des anderen zum gelegen
der liebe beiträgt die idee der
verschmelzung dass am ende doch
hochgradig lang weil nicht diese ja also
diese vorstellung nicht in sicht ja aber
diese diese möglichkeit sich auch wieder
sozusagen dem anderen als gegenüber zu
präsentieren und nicht in dieser
permanenten einheit auch gedanklich eine
eine möglichkeit zu sehen zwei leben als
ein singular mascha kaléko die dichterin
hat das sehr schön finde ich in einem in
einem gedicht geschrieben dass eben zwei
singular remis ein plural werden sondern
in dieser gemeinsamkeit etwas drittes
schaffen was liebe und freundschaft auf
unterschiedliche arten und weisen
möglich machen
dahinter steckt doch die sehnsucht der
einsamkeit zu erfliegen das ist doch
letztlich der treiber diese stechen der
einsamkeit und wenn man nur freunde hat
ist man letztlich doch immer wieder
anleihen
stirbt dabei ist dass das ist doch das
versprechen der romantischen das ist das
versprechen ja aber es ist die frage ob
wir nicht eben an diesem versprechen
mindestens ebenso leiden wie an der
möglichkeit für ein fach mit der
einsamkeit der letzten form von
einsamkeit es geht ja nicht darum dass
man alleine bleibt sondern dass man sich
auch mit dieser einsamkeit vielleicht
auch als etwas das wir vielleicht gar
nicht so tragisch beschreiben müssen
sondern wo es eben um eine letzte
unauflösbare form des nicht verstehens
seiner selbst das leben müsste eigenen
vergänglichkeit ich meine das ist der
beginn des philosophierens sich mit
dieser vergänglichkeit und dem letzten
alleinsein beschäftigen zu wollen und
daran wegbegleiter zu finden heißt ja
nicht dass ich zu dass ich zwingt mit
diesem wegbegleiter verschmelzen muss
jemand der das heißt sie ähnlich gesehen
hat ist der kultur philosoph und
soziologe georg simmel der hat nämlich
auch immer auch gesagt es bleibt
letztlich ein geheimnis und er sagt
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts die
freundschaft hat sich gewandelt
heute sollten wir von einer
differenzierten freundschaft sprechen
was meint er damit
er hat sich in seinen seinem also es
gibt einen text von ihnen die soziologie
der freundschaft in dem er sich versucht
mit diesem universal ideal der
aristotelischen freundschaft zu
beschäftigen davon abzugrenzen und zu
sagen eigentlich hat aristoteles mit
dieser vorstellung einer seele in zwei
körpern die eben dann auch diese form
der verschmelzung ein bisschen anbietet
zumindest da hat damit etwas gesät was
vielmehr unglück schafft als es
eigentlich teil eines glücklichen lebens
sein kann weil wir eben an diesem ideal
qua unseres individualisierten
menschseins scheitern müssen so dass er
gesagt die eigentliche qualität
menschlicher freundschaft muss darin
liegen dieses letzte geheimnis in etwas
zu integrieren was ich trotzdem als
lebenswert empfinden so dass er sagt
gekoppelt mit dem was er zu seiner zeit
als lebenswirklichkeit der einzelnen
gerade in den großstädten also er hat
aus berlin heraus philosophiert und hat
ebendort festgestellt dass sich die
lebenswelt durch industrialisierung
durch zunehmende mobilisierung also
mobilität andere technische
möglichkeiten ähnlich wie heute dass
sich daraus eben auch neue lebensformen
ergeben haben die eine andere soziale
kompetenz andere soziale beziehungen
notwendig gemacht haben und er gesagt
hat das was wir als differenzierte
freundschaft in diesem sich ständig
wandelnden immer vielfältiger werdenden
lebensformen erleben ist etwas was
sozusagen zu kleineren differenzierten
gemeinsamkeiten gemeinsame interessen
gemeinsame hobbys vielleicht auch ein
gemeinsames einen gemeinsamen lebens ort
an dem man sich trifft eine tiefe
erreichen kann die ähnlich wertvoll ist
wie das das aristoteles sozusagen auf
dieser universalen ebene beschrieben hat
nur dass wir eben von dem anderen nicht
mehr fordern müssen dass er unser ponton
ist unserer seelenverwandter sondern
dass es reicht in eine gemeinsamkeit zu
kommen von der aus sie sozusagen tief
tauchen können also wenn ich das richtig
verstehe dann heißt das wir haben dann
freunde mit denen wir bestimmte aspekte
unserer persönlichkeit teilen interessen
hobbys usw
also ich habe einen freund mit dem ich
tennis spiele mit einem 1 mit dem ich
philosophieren kann kochen usw das
problem ist doch keiner dieser freunde
kennt mich ganz und versteht mich auch
ganz und dieses moment des spiegels und
dass sich verstanden fühlen es und
angenommen fühlen so wie man eben ist
aus ganzer mensch dieses aufgehoben sein
das ist dann doch weg ja wenn er also
sinn hätte jetzt geantwortet dass das
sowieso nicht möglich ist also auch wenn
wir jetzt einen freund hätten wir dem
sie kochen und tanzen und philosophieren
und also all die dinge die ihnen
vielleicht wichtig sind teilen würden es
würde immer einen aspekt geben der
geheimnisvoll rätselhaft unentdeckt
bleibt das ist möglicherweise sogar für
sie selber auch ist und wo es dann eine
noch eine frage der quantität ist wie
viel von dem bleibt unentdeckt oder wie
viel von dem teile ich mit dem freund
nicht und würde sagen wir schaffen
sozusagen durch diese differenzierte
idee der freundschaft zwar einen
schmaleren zugang zu dem mann
aber darunter kann eben ein verstehen
möglich werden was denn überhaupt nicht
dem in nichts nachsteht
was aristoteles glaubte in der
freundschaft der trefflichen aufhalten
zu können
und jetzt seit sieben sie dann nochmal
100 jahre vergangen
die digitalisierung kann dazu facebook
kann dazu jetzt haben alle ganz viele
freunde präsentieren sich da freude
werden zwar ein statussymbol der
verdacht des narzissmus drängt sich auf
ihr leben in gestressten zeiten haben
wir nicht zeit es geht um effizienz ist
dann auch platz für freundschaft heute
es gibt auf jeden fall eine ungebrochene
sehnsucht nach freundschaft ich glaube
das ist erst mal als wichtiger gedanke
ganz klar festzuhalten also die
bedeutung und wir haben vorhin darüber
gesprochen
die frage ob freunde die bessere familie
sind das glaube ich ein ergebnis
sozusagen der moderne die deutlich macht
wie wichtig uns freundschaften heute
sind wie wie eh und je also darum gibt
es glaube ich keine unterscheidung was
die frage ist wie kompetent sind wir
weiterhin diese freundschaft all dieses
geworden wie schwierig ist es geworden
und die fähig sind wir uns eben in
dieser entscheidung für die freundschaft
dann auch um die ausdrucksformen zu
kümmern in denen freundschaft lebendig
wird also wie viel zeit verbringen wir
tatsächlich mit unseren freunden wie
gelingt freundschaft wenn ich fünf mal
in den letzten zehn jahren umgezogen bin
also welche form der nähe teile ich
tatsächlich also habe ich diese menschen
in meinem leben wie aristoteles
beschrieben haben oder sind sie am ende
eben nur noch eine anklickt oder eine
facebook seite wo er dann zumindest noch
die möglichkeit ist zu sagen ich habe
wenigstens noch facebook oder ich habe
eine digitale quelle um den anderen
menschen in dem was er jeden tag zu
verfolgen die frage ist nur wo findet
eben diese qualität dessen was wir als
freundschaft erleben und empfinden
tatsächlich staats und wo geht es eher
darum diese sehnsucht zum zum leben aber
eben als als eine art fragezeichen also
wo wir auf der suche
freundschaft sind und sie eben
eigentlich nicht gefunden haben diese
sehnsucht sucht sich heute ja schon
andere objekte künstliche objekt i will
ich sagen es gibt nichts freundschaften
mit robotern aber wenn man nach japan
schaut gibt es das phänomen dass man mit
hologrammen mit künstlichen systemen
befreundet ist zusammenbricht sogar
liebesbeziehung gelegt und wir schauen
uns dazu einen kurzen ausschnitt aus
einem werbespot an
ach ja
[Musik]
tokio
etwas
ja ist das die zukunft ich hoffe nicht
also es ist natürlich die frage jetzt
auch da wieder nach der henne und dem ei
also ist sozusagen diese hologrammen
idee eine reaktion auf eine note also
auf einen ein fehlen von freundschaft
auf dass man so gut wie es irgend geht
technisch reagiert oder versteht man
diese hologramme sozusagen als eine
weiterentwicklung von menschlichen
freundschaften weil wir jetzt sozusagen
den perfekten freund gefunden haben der
keine wünsche offen lässt und das darf
dann aber noch zu all dem was wir als
freundschaft beschrieben haben also kann
freundschaft perfekt sein darf sie
sozusagen von uns angeregt werden als
etwas was unser leben bereichern soll wo
wir selber in noten oder geht es nämlich
gerade darum diese note manchmal einfach
offensichtlich zu machen einfach mit
jemandem zu teilen
das würden sie sagen der war ihm besteht
der wert von beziehungen mit echten
menschen
genau jetzt zum schluss des gesprächs
möchte ich aber ein aspekt noch
aufmerksam machen wenn es um
freundschaft geht der ganz ganz zentral
ist und der bei schon bei den antiken
philosophen ganz zentral war nämlich die
freundschaft nicht mit anderen sondern
mit uns selbst ja also wir können auch
uns selbst ein guter freund sein oder
eben nicht
was also bei senica findet sich diese
mit dieser idee was was ist damit
gemeint und und wie wir erreicht man so
etwas wie selbst freundschaft die selbst
freundschaft versucht genau diese
aspekte die wir jetzt genannt haben also
diese sozusagen wohlwollende und aber
auch auf eine gewisse weise freiwillige
beschäftigung auf sich selbst zu
beziehen also diese schlichte frage wäre
ich gerne mein freund oder meine
freundin könnte ich mir vorstellen mit
mir selbst befreundet zu sein ist
manchmal schon eine frage die ziemlich
viele menschen ins zumindest ins
nachdenken und überraschende frage ja
also auch eine überraschende frage genau
also ich hab auch mal ich habe in einer
veranstaltung in ein teilnehmer gehabt
es war ganz großartig der ihm mit dieser
frage gar nicht
umfangen konnte und sich gewundert hat
wie so eine selbst beziehung überhaupt
aussehen kann also war wie es überhaupt
gelingen kann in so einem gespräch mit
sich selbst als freundschaftlich sein
könnte einzusteigen und hat dann aber so
nach einer gewissen zeit hat er
angefangen sich mit dieser frage zu
beschäftigen dass er wirklich nach der
veranstaltung dann kam sagte frau
schnitt wissen nicht ob ich habe heute
abend einen neuen freund und diese diese
möglichkeit also auch da vielleicht noch
mal angeknüpft an das an dann die frage
der einsamkeit auch mit sich selbst in
einen austausch zu treten der
freundschaftlich geprägt ist und der uns
dann aber auch in die ja also sozusagen
die kompetenz verleiht den anderen
unserem gegenüber ein freund sein zu
können also es würden sie sogar sagen
dass so etwas wie eine voraussetzung für
freundschaft was man ja das ist ja also
es klingt natürlich jetzt so als würde
man sagen ein programm abarbeiten müssen
man erstmal mit sich selbst befreundet
ist und dann in die welt zu gehen und
freunde zu suchen so ist das nicht
gemeint sondern die frage ist ja nur
wenn ich mich selbst nicht leiden kann
kann ich dann jemandes freund sein also
so zugespitzt und diese überlegung wie
ich mit mir selber in einem selbst
sorgen denn die antiken philosophen
hatten die idee der selbstsorge ja auch
als eine grundvoraussetzung dafür dass
ich ein bereichernder teil einer
gemeinschaft sein kann und damit eben
auch freundschaftliche verhältnisse auf
die weise führen kann wie wir es jetzt
besprochen haben und da glaube ich kann
hier noch eine menge von lernen wenn wir
dann gerade in diese diese nöte auch der
der prioritätensetzung der entscheidung
der frage was will ich eigentlich von
dieser oder jener freundschaft wenn ich
das mit mir selber beginne zu üben bin
ich glaube ich auf eine andere weise
vorbereitet dann auch in den austausch
mit anderen zu treten sind sie mit sich
selbst befreundet
immer mal wieder immer öfter also was
mir sehr geholfen hat das muss ich
wirklich sagen mit der in der
auseinandersetzung mit dem thema und
auch im schreiben des buches ist das ist
eine form von milde gegeben hat die
dazugekommen
die mir einfach das thema selbst sehr
viel leichter und zugänglicher hat
erscheinen lassen dass ich also diese
strenge in der beurteilung oder
verurteilung von dem was sich
freundschaft nennen würde sehr viel
stärker abgelegt habe als ich das vorher
getan hatte und in der lage bin einfach
auch momente der freundschaft oder
phasen der freundschaft wertzuschätzen
selbst wenn sie vielleicht an anderen
stellen die eine oder andere kritik oder
schwierigkeit oder was auch immer bereit
halten
mit diesem begriff dass selbst
freundschaft der ist ja nah dran an uns
selbst lieben und sie haben sie gesagt
das ist eigentlich freundschaftlich ist
eine form von leben steckt darin nicht
auch die gefahr des nazismus dann den
wir in unserer zeit viel erleben also
wie schafft man hat diese diese grenze
zu halten und das heißt selbst
freundschaft nicht so etwas mit egoismus
oder selbstverliebtheit wird ich glaube
es ist einfach eine bestimmte form von
von tatsächlich von demut also von frage
wie wichtig ich mich selber in diesen
zusammenhängen nehme also wenn ich mich
liebe heißt ja nicht dass ich mich
deshalb großartig oder ideal oder
perfect fällen muss sondern ich lerne es
vielleicht mich anzunehmen und liebevoll
zu betrachten auch in dem was nicht so
großartig denn nicht so wunderbar
gelungen ist und gerade deswegen aber
auch als freund oder freundin für ein
gegenüber was genau so wenig ideal oder
perfekt ist interessant zu bleiben und
lebendig zu bleiben ist glaube ich eine
ein gewinn
der glaube die idee der polarität sehr
viel stärker macht als es der
narzisstische gedanke dass es also
permanent um die eigene selbstbestimmte
spiegelung oder auch um die steigerung
des eigenen zu irgend etwas großartigem
gehen muss das widerspricht sich sogar
die frage ist eben nur wie bewusst gehe
ich mit dieser widersprechen
und der begriff der selbstliebe ist
ebenso gemeint also auch in der in der
steigerung vielleicht zur selbst
freundschaft aber ist so gemein dass es
eben einen einen einen liebevolle
betrachtung auch der eigenen ecken
kanten schwächen und schwierigkeiten
geben da
ina schmidt vielen herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch ja und nächste woche
erwartet sie hier ein fulminanter
höhepunkt vor der sommerpause barbara
bleisch trifft nämlich den
schriftsteller daniel kehlmann in berlin
anlass ist sein neues buch über den
dreißigjährigen krieg der vor genau 400
jahren ausgebrochen ist und jetzt
gleichzeitig die sternstunde kunst einen
film über den bahnbrechenden
österreichischen maler egon schiele der
vor 100 jahren verstorben ist und wir
oder wir sehen uns im herbst wieder
genießen sie anzuwenden sondern aufbaut
[Musik]